The correct answer is, if we know the optimization version to be tractable,
then the decision version is also tractable.
If we know it to be intractable, then the decision version is also intractable.
The same goes if we have the information about the decision version.
You see, the tractability of an optimization version
and of a decision version are closely related.
Now, two of these answers I think are more obvious than two others ones.
I think the answer to question #1 is rather obvious because if the optimization version is tractable
so you can find the best possible solution in polynomial time,
then with that solution you can also very easily answer a yes or no question about the solution.
The same thing is true I think for answer #4 because if the decision version is intractable
then the optimization version also has to be intractable or if you could easily solve
the optimization version then it would also be easy to answer a yes or no question about the solution.
The answers to question #2 and #3 I think are a little bit less obvious.
If you know the optimization version to be intractable, then of course it could be the case that
just having to say yes or no given the size of the solution that you're looking for
could be easier, that could be tractable.
So you would have to show in some way that if the decision version were tractable,
then the optimization version would also be easy to solve,
which is basically what I've asked you to think about in question #3 here.
One way to show this is and this is not very precise but just to give you an idea here that
if you have a tractable decision version then you could ask multiple questions
about the solution and still remain in polynomial time.
So for example if you're looking for the best possible solution for vertex cover,
you could first ask the decision version say for n/2 as the value of k you're looking for
and see if you can find a solution of this size.
If that is the case, you can decrease k or if you cannot find a solution that is that small
then you have to increase k and by solving the decision version often enough
so searching for that optimum k you can also solve the optimization version.
So this is not that obvious to see but for now you can keep in mind that optimization versions
of a problem and decision versions of a problem behave more or less the same
with respect to tractability or intractability.